hi I'm Victoria Elizabeth and I'm 15
years old
ha I'm Reggie I'm 20 hi my name is gift
and I'm 16 today we are going to be
playing a would you rather quiz social
media edition so the first question is
would you rather post an Instagram photo
that gets no likes or have the person
you're so tweeting like the tweet it's
basically tweeting about some body
without mentioning your name or adding I
would go for the second one I guess the
second because if you post a picture
like it's no likes everybody sees it you
know like what if you sub see one person
that's the only person a miss comment I
feel like I don't even know what so
tweeting is yeah I mean anyway the next
one is would you rather be tagged in an
unflattering picture or accidentally
like someone's photo from a year ago
oh the first one for sure I've done both
both happen to me and I would rather be
tagged in an unflattering picture
because what when someone figures out no
but you're like stalking there is I'd
rather I'd rather next thing like a fix
from a year ago
yeah that was a bad picture I just don't
want that I don't like that anywhere
because I know people are gonna see it
and I know my friends have spams and
I'll post it they'll expose me so I'm
thinking accidentally like someone's
photo from a year ago plus I can explain
to them I'll be like I can't do that
would you rather get facebook game
invites constantly or have it relatives
comment embarrassing things on pictures
I would go for have relatives comment
embarrassing things on pictures because
all they're gonna say is like look
you're doing this like or something like
that you know being your supporter
anyway but like Facebook game invites
what's the Facebook game advice it's
like they have games on Facebook where
you can like okay me yeah but like I
hate their notifications anyway so I
would just not want it to happen it's
just like getting a spam of
notifications of games you're not gonna
go oh yeah
yeah would you rather always have read
receipts turned on or have to manually
sign into an app every single time
already yeah they're mostly turned on I
probably tell you if I'm not gonna reply
for a long time yeah and yes sign in I
don't even know my Instagram password
and that's a lot every time you just
test your home button you got a sign all
the way back in type in your password
it's a lot of house would you rather
have your parents scroll through your
profile I have your crest grow through
your private messages have my parents
quotes both in my profile you say cuz I
don't post anything too inappropriate
could I like to have a good vision of
myself yeah I would go for parents I
mean she won't even she'll be like come
on these are nice pictures you know yeah
both of them are fine for me because
like DMS are like boring would you
rather be soft blocked or unfollowed
wait what was beyond follows I don't
follow
I don't want to deal with that DOMA yeah
I don't really care about followers
anyway I just say yeah actually I rather
be soft block because if you don't
follow me I'm gonna follow you back
anyway so if you soft block me just
gonna follow yourself so it makes it
easier I'll go for be soft block them
because he explained it would you rather
be followed by a celebrity you quite
like or have your favorite celebrity
replied to one of your tweets before me
because that means they action the exact
people yeah people know then you'll get
to know the people that they know right
if they follow you can actually meet the
person so I guess you had applying to
its we yeah maybe something else of you
actually
exactly replying to a tweet that's gonna
like no one's gonna see for another like
two months and then like be followed
like I can actually message them and
they'll receive it yeah and quite what
it says quite like I'd like so you
you're like chill with them like you
yeah yeah so I'll be good so I pretty
follow me and
vetting this watching us would you
rather give up Twitter or Instagram give
up Twitter because I own I barely know
how it works
I've just created an account like
probably like a year ago I didn't use it
like six months yeah and then when I got
on there I just read tweets and stuff
you can read on Instagram though
yeah you can't give up this degree yeah
oh really
I like Twitter you interact a lot more
people because of pretreat sand you
exactly see a lot of funny stuff huh
yeah it's more community based on
Twitter and then Instagram is more
here's what I'm doing with my life like
look at it so I would go with Twitter
because like all I can see where mr.
Graham has everything Twitter has just
less community based but yeah I'd go
with give up Twitter I have a lot of the
same opinions as other people based on
social media I feel like a lot of people
especially kind of relate to these
questions I feel like this was like good
test to see how people thinking but I
also like to learn some new vocabulary
that I never knew existed so that was
fun
[Music]